well um
there's a level of inhumanity
in what we've seen in buchia
that first and foremost cannot go
unpunished that's exactly why canada is
petitioning the international criminal
court and we're also providing expertise
to make sure that the investigation is
ongoing and ongoing fast why because we
need to collect the evidence and those
who committed these war crimes and
crimes against humanity must be
held to account and
our goal is to make sure that ukrainians
are able to defend themselves uh and
that we're putting maximum pressure on
the russian regime our goal is to
suffocate the russian regime
and so by making
weapons available to ukrainians and by
having strong sanctions
we think that this is the best way not
only for ukrainians to be strong
on the battlefield but meanwhile also to
make sure that they have a strong
position at the negotiation table
we think that
we have to all do our part canada has
been providing lethal weapon and
humanitarian aid to ukraine and will
continue to do that i'll be working with
my colleague minister of defense on this
and meanwhile i must say
we
on the question of sanctions so we
welcome
the sanctions package
that has been expressed by the eu will
continue to coordinate with our european
colleagues meanwhile yesterday canada
announced new sanctions and
we will in the coming days announce more
sanctions our goal is to make sure that
there's no loopholes that there's
complete unity and that we can make sure
to put
a lot of pressure maximum pressure on
the russian regime just like i just
mentioned
and i think the other thing also i
wanted to
mention
is
canada is very seized
with what happened over the weekend like
mentioned
and
my deputy minister so i instructed my
deputy minister to summon the russian
ambassador in ottawa to make sure that
he is presented with the images
of what happened in european and bucha
don't you feel
that russia sees
defensive of offensive weapons
as a threat against them and see nato as
cut this war
i think at this point russia knows very
well where canada stands
and we are there to make sure that no
more civilian lives are lost due to this
this uh unjustifiable unconscionable
further invasion of uh ukraine by russia
the secretary general says that he
expects a new russian offensive
in the south and the donbass region so
russia can have a land bridge through
marriage
there's already lots of civilians
trapped in marion
do you fear that there have already been
atrocities committed there to people who
are just trying to survive
listen this is something that keeps me
up at night
and this is something that keeps
i think
all foreign ministers and all our
governments up at night
because we know that the situation in
madrid is extremely dire we know that
people
need to have access to food and to clean
water
we've supported ukrainians in their call
to make sure that there is a
humanitarian corridor unfortunately
because of the bad faith of russians
this has not
been uphold and we call
russia to make sure that they can offer
a form of security to civilians in
mariopol
if they don't do so they know that war
has rules
and the geneva convention
is
something that all countries should be
abiding by and therefore when they do
not abide by the rules
and the convention and the u.n charter
they're committing war crimes and
they're committing also crimes against
humanity
and they will be held accountable